[Music]
bellmore new york a busy commuter town
about 30 minutes from new york city and
home to a wide variety of restaurants
for 10 years the mixing bowl has managed
to survive but now with increased
competition it's only months away from
closing he said cajun not asian
my name is billy goletti i'm the chef
owner of the mixing bowl
pick it up i'm the chef delivery guy mr
fix it doing bills picking up supplies i
mop the floors if i have to it's what i
have to do to keep the place alive
the mixing bowl eatery has been here for
10 years lisa is this order right you
know what you should see a manager not
your wife if it was up to billy's wife
the restaurant would be closed next week
it says two muscles should say one
my hope is really gone for this
how bad place it yesterday disaster six
people came in the restaurant all night
last night everyone just knows he's
mixing ball mike right this way young
ladies yes he's the manager but it's
impossible to work with him you get five
times more pay than the servers what the
hell is your problem
kind of like one big happy family what
you just said makes absolutely no sense
that doesn't make sense
shut up
mike what are you doing
i'm taking a drink is i'm parched he is
the manager oh my god
what does mike do now
oh
[Music]
i see him schmooze a lot
people come in here and they think i'm
the owner they call me like the mayor of
belmore
do they do that because they respect me
they fear me i don't know
shut up and let me finish talking you
know
nobody's gonna listen to someone who's
yelling at them like a madman talking to
you is like talking to a brick wall all
right all right all right
when the mixing bowl first opened it was
busy every week you know it was really
doing well [ __ ] the people man
now it's just slow
everybody's like depressed
we tried everything that we can there is
no more money
there
is
nothing else to do
if something doesn't change and someone
doesn't help us out the restaurant could
be closed next week now it's at the end
of the road i'm so stubborn about
keeping it alive but am i hurting myself
am i hurting my family you're holding
everything up now with all this crap i'm
sorry that's what i wrote our marriage
gets affected by his business go go out
go out we're struggling seven days a
week that
puts a damper on our relationship i
can't sacrifice myself and our children
for the mixing bowl anymore
if it's not gonna work it's time to walk
away
[Music]
gordon ramsay has just one week to
uncover the restaurant's problems devise
a plan and find a way for this
restaurant to stand out in this
competitive market i'm nervous because
this looks dreadful
[Music]
oh my god
it's a pleasure to have you here not at
all sorry gordon first name my client
mike nice to see you it's exciting just
like oh my god like i'm meeting gordon
ramsay you know to me he's a god in the
restaurant industry
good to see you hi
lisa nice to see you
god
well this is quiet
this is this is this is typically staff
one two three four how many book for
lunch nobody
no no when gordon first came in i was
nervous and i hope he's just not too
hard on all of us i'm gonna sit here yes
this is the lunch menu and what style of
restaurant is it it's new american type
cuisine salad some wraps a little bit of
pizza like a health spa
um where was the last time you went to a
spa
the gym
what are you saying are you trying to
say i'm asking what was the last time
you went to the gym
uh not for a long time
when was last time we had a salad
not for a long time
right okay if you have any questions
please feel free to ask okay great
when you look at the way the rest is put
together you can identify instantly from
the paper cloths to the drapes to the
plants the ceiling to the color that
this ration really is on its last legs
there's not long to go here
award-winning maryland lump crab cakes
said north atlantic salmon sun-dried
tomato basil for such a small restaurant
the menus are huge
you need a couple of minutes i'm dying
to taste the award-winning marathon crab
cakes they are excellent an award
winning well what do they win
you could ask billy he knows more about
it i thought you would know about it if
you're the manager and it's on your menu
well i i anyway i
i'll have a zucchini pancake okay and
i'll go for the sad north atlantic
salmon i think okay thank you
god that guy needs some spark
bean bag he is intimidating to serve
okay these are the maryland crab cakes
thank you and the zucchini pancakes the
chive sour cream lovely thank you enjoy
thank you
[Music]
may i ask what you think of the crab
cakes
may i ask you not to stare at me
absolutely makes me feel really
uncomfortable
you know i got this cockroach on your
back you're trying to shake off and i
like to just sit and enjoy my lunch
absolutely thank you so much
award-winning maybe not in terms of
freshness yeah i wouldn't expect to find
something so fresh in such a dreary
dreadful dining room
[Music]
zucchini pancakes stodgy bland and it's
pretty thick
it's like having a mouthful of glue
[Music]
oh my god what's that on top tomato
basil
there's no garlic where's the garlic
from is that on the green beans there's
shallots there's no garlic no garlic in
any of the ingredients and then on the
beans
looks like there's garlic on here
why don't you just check with him i can
smell it anyway i will that looks like
garlic thank you
billy what the string beans you cook
them in garlic yeah
is there any shallots in there at all no
shells
[Music]
sounded very bland and a sauce just
heavy soggy and vinegary
garlic everywhere no one wants to come
out to lunch and stink of garlic that's
for sure
you know billy's getting a little
nervous like am i about to get rings
right now you know
[Music]
i don't know what to expect to be honest
when you first walk in that dining room
you get this depressing manager
jumping on you which is a great shame
i'm sure five years ago you had some
form of spark the food
the crab cakes were good thanks yes
that was the high point
everything else unfortunately for me
just
planned
pancakes was soggy and fish was dry the
salmon just it just looked old-fashioned
can i ask you an honest question yes it
was our 10-year anniversary and we say
for our senior adversary everybody gets
confidential yes now everybody tells me
they love them if you give something
away and it's free who's going to
complain about it
that never happens so either
he's crazy or every customer comes in
here is lying to me want to come back
with a plan and bang it didn't blow me
away today i'm not that excited about it
it's very average very dreary and it's
very sad
end of story
okay see you later yes
it makes me feel terrible when gordon
says he doesn't like my husband's food
you know of course i'm going to take the
offense to that
gordon is wrong about the restaurant my
position is the manager so i am not
intimidated by anybody
bring it on
[Music]
later that night after meeting the staff
and sampling the food gordon wants to
observe a dinner service so he can
evaluate billy in the kitchen and mike
in the front of the house how many of
you got booked tonight
two or three people bloody hell
jesus
this is not very good right now it is
seven o'clock and there's a lot of open
tables in the restaurant
to me
i would have shut the doors a year ago
wherever you feel like it's your trip
why not
it's an hour into the dinner service and
it's starting to become clear to gordon
why the mixing bowl is losing so much
money
this coupon you can use it this evening
50 off your check is all adjusted thank
you very much thank you
what's going on here i'm taking 50 off
my check we hand somebody a check
you put this 50 off coupon in it fifteen
fifty no no five oh fifty
in here yeah fifty percent off holy
smoke so we're giving more money away
before we get money in the till
my goodness me
jesus
mike's just told me about a coupon that
he tried how long have you been doing it
um
long time
eight years eight years price
that doesn't wake since then does it no
it doesn't
do you ever go out there
um
yeah when i
you know it dies down i'll walk around
while billy spends the entire dinner
service in the kitchen the
responsibility of running the restaurant
is in mike's hands any more coupons
anywhere else no no that's for sure
nothing at all
there is more i have about 10 signs that
i had made up
go and get them
[Music]
someone grab the door for me please
sorry
[Music]
sorry
okay
all of them go in the window at some
point
where did you get all these frogs i have
a place they make them up for me it was
expensive holy mackerel as you can see
i tried everything
clearly
now accepting reservations maybe because
we're not taking reservations maybe
people aren't coming in here
it's empty yes
but we did it [ __ ] empty
tuesday night dinner special select
three three one that was that was one of
the worst things we've ever done um
so we did a select three it was it was a
while ago we did um and that's a pumpkin
can i can i tell you what because i mean
listen read this order your thanksgiving
desserts early yes in case we're closed
by time we come around to november what
i do is i i'll put up a sign a month
ahead of time because maybe people will
drive out and say oh look which sign was
the most successful
none
none is there anything else that i
should know
that's it
that is it
well there's oh well
oh no
it was honestly it's not really that big
of a deal
[Applause]
gordon can you come here it's a little
big
what in the [ __ ]
free appetizer with dinner oh [ __ ] um
man get me out of here
jesus christ
where in the
it went over it went over the you saw
these other little signs weren't working
and how long did the soil go for well it
would have still been up but there was a
a bad wind storm a few months ago and it
ripped it down it blew the signs down
yes thank [ __ ] for that doesn't this
catch your eye though from the street
catch my eye isn't that the point it's
[ __ ] worse than a dollar shop
you're incredible okay get the signs and
put them back around here i don't want
any customers to see it
i've got a russian tour who's just a
cook a simple cook a manager totally
obsessed by his signs and a wife i'd
rather close the place down tonight this
is a real nightmare
my god
after a day of observation gordon is
ready to confront billy and lisa with
the harsh reality
i've got to be [ __ ] brutally honest
with you you know that
i've seen a lot today watch the service
unfortunately i spent a lot of time
talking to mike and uh yeah he's uh he's
out there that one huh
you seriously have to start thinking as
a businessman not leaving it to someone
like michael to sort of focus on the
baloney and [ __ ] and then watching
you cooking i've never ever seen
a chef so quiet in all my life
you look like a man that's dying to be
put out of his misery lisa you may be
right
to put you out your misery
maybe we should close this place down
[ __ ] tonight
after the dinner service gordon decides
to test billy and lisa's commitment to
the restaurant lisa you may be right
to put you out your misery
maybe we should close this place down
[ __ ] tonight
stress and the pressure relieved bang
would be gone within 12 hours
some reason
i don't want him to give up his dream
but i don't see why we keep going with
it
billy's a good person he doesn't want to
just walk away but if he has to close
the doors it needs to be closed then and
let's move on already i want to live a
normal life
this is where you
really seriously dig deep
if the restaurant dies it'll be like a
death in the family we have to go
forward and turn this around
seriously no
if you seriously seriously want to
continue you have got to find your
passion
with your support and truthfully unless
you change you'll be gone in six weeks
time
[Music]
it's day two and time for gordon to
start implementing his plan
he hopes to get through to manager mike
about his destructive promotions with
the help of a somewhat destructive
measure
[Music]
looks like a wood chipper to me that's
right
it's time to say goodbye to the past
it's time to say goodbye to valentine's
day
[Music]
[Applause]
you're mad there yeah i am [ __ ] mad
working with guys like you makes me
[ __ ] mad
with gordon struggling to get through to
mike he now turns his attention to the
mixing bowl's greatest challenge
let's have a look at 1997 first
one
two three four restaurants wow yeah
ten years ago let me show you something
2007.
holy [ __ ] look how built up this
neighborhood's become over the last 10
years 41 restaurants from a chinese to a
deli to a pizza to a diner right now we
need to reposition the mixing bowl
smack bang in the middle of all that
competition gordon's right 41
restaurants of course you're gonna kind
of get lost in the shuffle what else is
around this area you go to every day oh
the gym gyms
beauty parlors telling salons what isn't
on
there a healthier healthy is something
that's not even lifted anywhere near
here one way we can help turn this
around is by installing something to do
with
health
it's exciting to realize you can do
things healthy and just open my eyes to
a whole world give the [ __ ]
neighborhood what they want
with the mixing bowl now embracing being
the healthy high quality restaurant of
bellmore gordon also realizes he needs
to ignite billy's passion time to be
competitive
creative yeah our list of 15 ingredients
okay half an hour
you work there i work there keep it
fresh and healthy think about the
direction
of the ration the way it's going yes
okay
gordon ramsay teaching billy he's being
trained by one of the top chefs in the
world
i was totally into what i was doing but
then like you realize that's gordon
ramsay working next to you here it was
great so you shredded the fennel same
way i've shredded it i hope you're not
copying me buddy man
i did the fiddle first and then you're
copying me oh dude i was so excited
because i haven't seen billy this fired
up about something in so long you're
very quiet there my man [ __ ] you now
what is it with you you must drive lisa
around the bend you know that how did
you communicate through email i wasn't
paying attention to what he was doing at
all i was more involved in just making
my dish let's go my man
that [ __ ] up by the way
will you finish first
okay good so yours is a sealed salmon
with ginger balsamic drizzle this is a
poached salmon i just poached in a
vegetable stock topped with a walnut
pesto
everything looked really nice just fresh
and lively and vibrant and the food kind
of like jumped out of you look great
this is the kind of food that the mixing
bowl should be serving
i like that
both dishes are good enough to go on the
menu tonight i like the food but i
really don't know if gordon can change
this place around
[Music]
with word that world-class chef ramsay
is in town the mixing bowl is busier
than normal for tonight's dinner service
you have reservations this evening
but can the staff at the mixing bowl
actually cope with a busy restaurant
this is someone special yeah you think
that the customer's absolutely gonna
love the new salmon dish crusher salad
don't point don't point to customers
we're running a restaurant not a [ __ ]
zoo
[Music]
did you get the salmon special yeah okay
good let's take 12 out let's take 12
hours do you like salmon yeah i would
try salmon three famine specials good
we're selling the salmon goods
hey van hey dan smith
i don't particularly care about the
kitchen your main focus should be the
customers the water is complimentary
he working now all he does is stand and
talk and lean and pray
[Laughter]
summer special is really going well but
michael what the [ __ ] is he doing this
guy is just [ __ ] using this
restaurant to feed his ego but i'm glad
you guys are enjoying everything you
want your friends to come in that's
great but you should be out working
answer the phone please it's impossible
to work with him and every time you work
with him he takes half of your tips
kimmy you're gonna work the tips baby i
get very large tips give them some water
and table 18 clothes i mean
20-25 percent can you do you have to put
on another round of drinks another bud
another bud and another diet coke also
i'm tired of
mike taking half the money from the tip
cop that's not fair goodbye thank you
[Music]
despite the success of the new specials
the staff is unhappy with their tips and
all fingers are pointing toward mike you
find a table you latch on and then the
rest of us bust our butts to get your
tables and our tables done and then you
take a half like a vortex can i can i
say something
do you think you would have those tips
if i wasn't here
when people come in here everybody knows
me the customers know me and all you
guys know that people know me the best
because i make it a point of making
friends with customers and that's what
customers want they want to feel special
mike thinks this is his restaurant he is
an employee here
[ __ ] unbelievable
okay time to get real when i ask you to
wake up in terms of running the [ __ ]
business sometimes you run it as if you
own the place and the reason why you do
that is because billy you are too weak
and at least if it sounds crap open up
and say it i'm nervous that everybody's
sitting here with their thumbs up their
asses and not doing what they're
supposed to be doing i don't think right
now that's the right attitude i think we
should have a positive attitude i mean
be realistic when i'm busting my own
tables and everybody else is running
around crazy we are aware of what the
problems were
and i think that we should move forward
and put the damn pass behind us you're
kind of talking to yourself right now
i'm talking uh this is how i feel i am
verbal these are things you need to do
i'm fighting for my life here
[Music]
you right now need to step up to the
plate and make the changes every
freaking day every minute of the day
that's it
billy
that's the first time
you sounded like a boss
because it's your [ __ ] life on the
line don't ever forget that
hey
he's laughing again if you're carrying
the weight that this guy and his wife
has on their shoulders you wouldn't
[ __ ] smirk
[Music]
tomorrow the most important day in 10
years we're gonna implement changes to
help get this business turned around if
this doesn't work after tomorrow the
blame
is on your shoulders mike
[Music]
still to come let's go the mixing bowl
is busier than ever pick up this plate
let's go can i get the three suits now
yeah it's coming now you [ __ ] out i
was just fed up but nobody is in the
mood for celebrating i was told seven
o'clock this morning that's it
it's the dinner service you have to see
to believe seriously i'm pissed off do
not talk to me like that
day three
gordon's design team works overnight and
transforms the mixing bowl from a
non-descript diner into a contemporary
sleek restaurant and now it's time to be
revealed
right ready
yes mike ready
i'm so excited to see like what you know
i'm psyched place needs a facelift so
i'm very excited to see it let's go
lovely
here we go
come down wow it's gorgeous
[Music]
oh
jesus yes
[Music]
no kissing huh
looks nice ah beautiful this is gorgeous
i feel like i want to spend money in
here
it's exciting to walk out to the dining
room and just seeing what it looks like
the decor was terrible
now i think the decor works it fits with
the food it fits with the name lisa what
do you think of the chairs oh my god sit
down
have a seat
[Music]
it's beautiful
oh my god
it's amazing it just was like a gift it
was just like a period of grace
it really touched me deeply it looks
like a restaurant now doesn't it yes are
you serious start spending time in your
own restaurant now you're saying hello
to customers yep kim how do you feel
dunny it looks completely different i
feel so much better about coming here
knowing that they're not looking around
thinking why am i sitting here with this
gross paper on my table
it's gorgeous
i can't wait for customers to come
[Music]
sorry
i can't wait for customers to come in
and see the place jesus lisa if you want
any tissues
hey
this is our new start so
hopefully
it's what we needed it's unbelievable
[Music]
with the new decor as the inspiration
it's time for gordon to overhaul the
menu
okay first salad apple and on the salad
yes and it's done with walnuts and honey
dijon dressing very fresh fragrant very
citrusy very tangy gordon woke me up he
got me back to what's now and just
trying to put that together under
gordon's direction the mixing bowl has
removed heavily sauced entrees and
replaced them with healthy vibrant items
roasted fine tomato soup slowly roasted
in the oven overnight blended and it's
finished with fresh basil and drizzled
olive oil tuna nicoise has been dressed
with an olive tepenard green beans
olives eggs and roasted new potatoes
there we got to see the way all the new
dishes looked they looked beautiful
smaller portions lighter foods all of it
made sense
good right are we ready yeah yes good
luck i love the menu because i was
eating all the food in here so now i'm
eating a little bit healthier it may uh
may have an impact on my belly
with a healthy new menu and the
restaurant redesigned it's time to
utilize the staff's new energy and
spread the word about the new mixing
bowl we'll go out to a spa a gym we'll
just put the word out fresh outlook
fresh appeal my god look at these hi
guys you all know what the mixing bowl
is right that's the russian there the
mixing bowl
we're going to be kicking off our new
light vibrant healthy menu exciting new
food it'd be great to see at the mixing
bowl eatery in balmoral new deck all new
menu new style
yes
gordon jordan i'm burning 700 calories
per hour if billy can see you right now
not bad for a fat guy huh
i brought you here for a wake-up call
yeah let's go
in keeping with the healthy direction of
the restaurant gordon has reached out to
the new york dragons arena football team
to create some buzz in the community
big day for us tomorrow so
we want to help celebrate that and
maybe get you down to the restaurant and
come have a bite to eat i think it's an
amazing idea i just hope it works
[Music]
[Music]
day four
only a short time before relaunch and
mike is already feeling the heat there's
a couple of little tiny things that
bother me because i want i want the
place to look perfect next thing while
mike speaking can i help you how many
people are you gonna be there was a lot
of confusion with the reservations and
there was a lot of things that i really
had to do myself disgusting okay he's
having a hard time today which we all
were you know but he really lost it
actually all right
this is why we need xanax mike just
seemed so stressed and i was definitely
concerned that it wasn't going to help
us when we opened the doors that's it
that's it
[Music]
with the relaunch only minutes away
everything seems to be in place for the
big night
it looks like we have 47 and the
restaurant is fully booked
good luck
yes
let's go big boy
customs are queuing up to get here jesus
christ
unfortunately there were too many
reservations set at the same time oh no
even i'm getting a little bit [ __ ]
doolally there'll be a van picking me up
in a minute with a [ __ ] straight
jacket
[Music]
[ __ ] madness
[Music]
it's the mixing bowl's biggest night and
because of mike's reservations mix-up
many of the customers have arrived at
the same time how you doing how's
everything as soon as those doors open
and the floodgates opened up and
everyone kind of came at once it was a
little bit stressful just give me two
seconds mike yes right come over coming
okay
reservations what's the hiccup
i handed over the reservation list to
kim and then i'm not exactly sure what
transpired since then
mike tried to blame the reservation mix
up on me
i've never been the one in charge of the
reservations
it's not here
this is a big night i cannot tell you
how big this night is and you've got to
know what's coming in that's your job
it's not solely my fault and i don't
think that it's right to put blame on
any one person can we get on yes and
work as a team yes god
after gordon's pep talk lynne kim and
lisa all stepped in to help get everyone
seated
totally different menu what would you
like to see
see
with the dining room now completely full
for the first time in years the pressure
was turned up on the mixing bowl staff
mike you had table five i'm not even
are you telling him to there a bus pin
let me tell that for you please thank
you dude can you wake up
wake up this is our one shot to make our
lasting impression we're gonna blow it
how long are the appetizers on table
[ __ ] all right you can't drive me crazy
right now
honestly i think mike's job's not that
hard
he just gets sidetracked and
stops stops being a manager
while each waiter is covering three to
four tables all right so let me go ahead
mike is looking after his friends all
right
can i get the three soup i need two soup
now yeah it's coming now you [ __ ]
hell watch your back watch your back i
was definitely concerned that mike was
gonna crumble
he's not used to running a [ __ ] busy
dining room out there you know that yeah
my god
where's mine
[Music]
oh my
god [ __ ] it now
it's two hours into dinner service and
the mixing bowl has weathered the first
storm but they are about to be faced
with another challenge the new york
dragons
[Music]
hi how are you
you're gonna have a nice dinner
okay okay so we're just gonna get your
tables together
okay
all right we'll be right with you
wait a minute i thought that that table
was going to be with them
can i see this
[Music]
you forgot the biggest thing to put on
the list the dragon's reservation the
dragons were supposed to be on that list
and somehow mike just forgot how is that
missed how is that they just someone did
dragons just like that's not what i'm
saying i'm not exactly sure what
transpired it's beyond upsetting there
was no dragons on there my god that
table for me is the most important table
that's
embarrassing you're overlooking
extremely important thing
i was not told about the dragons i found
out like why you keep saying that
because i wasn't i wasn't told
excuse me do not talk to me like this
seven o'clock this morning
that's it seriously i'm pissed off
dragon's on the paper
i'm pissed off
not my fault
dragons right over here i put them on at
seven o'clock can we please move on
that's it
not my fault
it's relaunch night for the mixing bowl
and mike's reservation mishap with the
new york dragons has caused him to go
over the edge
i wasn't told do not talk to me like
that pissed off that's it
i was told seven o'clock this morning
not my fault dragons on the paper
[Music]
i mean can we please move on that's it
we were all in shock and speechless
i've seen him blow up before but that
was a new there's a new level right
there hey yes you [ __ ] off outside now
jesus christ
[Music]
this is like the twilight zone
i really think something in his brain
has snapped he's a freaking lunatic
[Music]
mike was raising his voice i mean i
don't want him to talk to my wife that
way i don't go for that
mike's conduct has everyone rattled and
gordon has some concerns for the
restaurant owners
[Music]
let me just tell you something
and i've got to be brutally honest
you've got one problem here
[Music]
mike
i don't know why billing lisa weren't
talking to gordon i don't know what they
possibly could have said about me
you
need a manager and
that is not your man
business is business if something's got
to be done to change in this place we
gotta change it
that's the restaurant business freaking
fire em
[Music]
if i would go home right now
life goes on
i'd get another job
but my life would be different
[Music]
i just got to reevaluate the situation
mike's gonna have to change like the
place has changed so everybody else in
the place is gonna get a second chance
so it might shoot me a second chance and
we're gonna move forward together
for now billy has decided to keep mike
on as manager
move on yeah that was
embarrassing yeah
can we put an end to this
i feel like i'm reborn again and we are
going to build the best damn restaurant
that
that
ever existed or at least
in a 25 mile radius all right table
two's getting up we're gonna push it
together for a table of four
mike managed to find a place to seat the
dragons and it looks like gordon has
finally gotten through to him
ready
i have a new new look new restaurant
thank you so much for coming i
appreciate it i'm gonna get your dinner
out real quick all right good job good
job
for the first time he said thank you to
me
so that was like wow all of a sudden
you know like was that him
it was great service has been excellent
i give the service
although the mixing bowl's relaunch had
some growing pains it's clear the
restaurant is headed in the right
direction
[Music]
as the week
progressed mike's management skills kept
improving
one and two is crucial that we get out
of here
the customers raved about the vibrant
food i love the new menu it's so
different it feels great right we got
some amazing feedback from the food
billy
everybody's really loving the food
holy moly
the profits were soaring what each
person spends on average went up
by like double in the spirit of the new
healthy menu gordon sponsored the first
ever mixing bowl mile run
come on mike come on mike you're an
eight-year-old is beating you and with
the restaurant thriving billy even found
some time to hang out with his new
friends the dragons
this journey was unbelievable
i'm excited to go forward that's what i
want to see that passion yes
and on gordon's last day he even got shy
billy to finally come out of the kitchen
i want you to stop what you're doing for
two minutes and go say hello to your
customers
i'm so proud of him couldn't be more
proud of him i want him to get a little
recognition for all that he does
thank you so much
the difference tonight from when i first
arrived was extraordinary
i would seriously eat here
your talented big boy you've got to make
that transition from a chef to
restauranteur
i got the message on how i have to
change to make this place the best it
could be
start thinking of cooking up there
not with your bag
yes come on thank you so much
the black cloud has definitely been
lifted off this restaurant we can't
blame anyone but ourselves now because
there's no excuses left
ladies for oh
it all came together and i just can't
wait to go forward good night thank you
thank you
[Music]
two months have gone by and the
restaurant is continuing to prosper
[Music]
gordon he just let everything out on me
it was like rip on mike week but he
definitely did teach me some things we
had fun with it
as for billy and lisa their marriage is
as strong as the restaurant itself
the changes i've seen in our
relationship is amazing so for that
gordon i thank you that means so much to
me
[Music]